Rey training scenes, a showdown between BB-8
and BB-9E, a crazy Porg moment, and Poe and
Finn in Canto Bight, are just some of the
many deleted scenes from Star Wars: The Last
Jedi.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm revealing and explaining a stack
of cut scenes and rejected concepts from Episode
8.
Although The Last Jedi is the longest movie
in the Star Wars saga so far, director Rian
Johnson has confirmed there's at least half
an hour of deleted scenes and even more unused
footage and he's promised there will be plenty
of extra scenes on the Blu-ray.
Just before I get into that, I'm starting
a second round of my Star Wars giveaway.
To enter, make sure you're a subscriber and
leave me a comment with your thoughts about
the deleted scenes.
I'll announce the winner of the first round
later in the video.
Oh, and if this is your first time on my channel,
I do regular deleted scenes videos, movie
breakdowns, easter eggs, theories and giveaways.
Quick spoiler warning, I'll be discussing
scenes from The Last Jedi in detail, so take
care if you've not watched it yet.
Let's start on Ahch'To where Rian Johnson
has confirmed there was a huge scene cut which
showed Rey performing a type of additional
trial and then a very emotional scene between
Rey and Luke afterwards.
Now, if you remember, Luke told Rey he'd teach
her three lessons, but in the movie we only
saw her complete two of those before she decided
to leave the island to try and turn Kylo Ren
to the light side.
Which makes me think the third lesson was
going to be the trial or test that was cut
from the movie.
There's some incredible artwork in the Art
of The Last Jedi book which shows Rey facing
off against two figures or visions which resemble
Darth Vader and Obi Wan Kenobi, the choice
of the light and the dark side to Rey.
The fact that Rey's standing in water here
suggests it could be an alternate version
of the mirror scene in the movie, with Luke
having told Rey to enter the island's Cave,
just as Yoda told Luke to enter the Dark Side
Cave on Dagobah in The Empire Strikes Back.
And other concept art also seems to indicate
that the cave scene might have explored the
duality of the light and the dark side in
addition to Rey's parentage as it did in the
movie.
Other possibilities for Rey's deleted training
scene include footage from the trailer and
behind-the-scenes reel of her running with
a lightsaber on the beach.
Concept art of this scene shows that Rey was
running towards the Caretaker village where
you can see some fires.
And in another piece of concept art, Rey and
Luke are on a cliff where they spot marauders
approaching the village, which makes me think
maybe the village was attacked and Rey attempted
a rescue.
Alternately, the fires in the village might
be from a scene that looks like a Caretaker
celebration, which means Rey's beach run could
be showing her training while the island's
inhabitants are enjoying themselves.
Concept art also indicates there could have
been a scene of Rey practising her skills
with numerous training remotes which could
have been fun to see.
An old training remote popped up in The Force
Awakens when Finn picked it up on the Millennium
Falcon, and seeing Rey in a scene like this
could have been a nice call back to Episode
4 when Luke briefly used one to train with
Obi Wan Kenobi.
There's also a separate deleted and extended
sequence with Rey and the Caretakers.
The Art of The Last Jedi book reveals that
one particular Caretaker, the matron, "has
a problem with Rey being on the island, [as]
Rey [is] intruding in this private world,
and in this private relationship that they
have with Luke."
There was a little allusion to this deleted
scene in the film when Rey mentioned to Luke
that she didn't think the Caretakers liked
her.
And there's a load more unused concept art
featured in the Art of book.
Some of my favourites include Luke and Rey
on a skiff on their way to the old Jedi temple
which in this version was carved into the
side of the island.
Another cool shot had Rey accessing the temple
via a cliff.
And in this version of the Jedi temple, the
entrance was specifically designed to resemble
the window behind the Emperor's throne in
Return of the Jedi, the idea being to show
that the early symbols of the Jedi have been
used by both the light and the dark sides.
After Finn wakes up towards the start of the
film, there's a deleted scene where he finds
out what happened while he was unconscious.
Basically, BB-8 plays a hologram of Rey's
scene in The Force Awakens where she kisses
Finn on the forehead and says "We'll see each
other again".
It's interesting this was deleted because,
in The Last Jedi, Finn has a brief romantic
moment with Rose after she saves him on Crait.
And later in the Millennium Falcon, you can
see Rey looking at Finn while he takes care
of Rose.
BB-8 also had another deleted scene where
he squared off against his evil counterpart
BB-9E.
Creature effects creative supervisor Neal
Scanlan told EW that The Last Jedi would feature
"a lovely moment between BB-8 and BB-9E, which
[would tell a] sort of parallel story of Vader
and Luke."
We did get that pretty insane moment of BB-8
commandeering a First Order walker on the
Supremacy, and some scenes of BB-8 and BB-9E
together did appear in a Last Jedi-themed
ad for Verizon, but it was a shame we didn't
get a showdown between these two droids in
the actual movie.
The story on Canto Bight was changed significantly
numerous times during The Last Jedi's development.
Initially, that part of the movie was going
to feature Finn and Poe Dameron, rather than
Finn and Rose Tico.
When Rian Johnson reviewed his early script
though, he discovered that Finn and Poe's
story in the wealthy casino city wasn't exciting
enough because there was no conflict between
the two characters as, in some ways, they
were too alike.
So, Poe was replaced with Rose, who challenges
Finn and therefore allows his character to
develop during the course of the film.
Interestingly, in early drafts, Finn was also
going to be part of the Resistance fighter
squadron in the opening battle.
In fact, he was going to be on the same ship
as Rose's sister, Paige, and actually witness
her death.
However, Rian Johnson pulled the plug on this
part of Finn's story when he realised that
including a big scene where Finn had to reveal
this to Rose would slow the movie down.
Even after the story settled on Rose and Finn
in Canto Bight, there were still several more
changes to that part of the movie.
Originally, after arriving in the city, the
pair were going to break into a shop to steal
a gown and tuxedo so they'd blend in better
in the casino.
Additionally for Rose, putting on the gown
was going to be a kind of transformation moment
from her practical Resistance overalls.
And a tuxedo-clad Finn was going to enjoy
getting a lot of attention in the casino,
until he discovered he'd put on his tux back-to-front.
After this scene was deleted, Finn and Rose's
lack of disguise meant they were easy to spot
and apprehend, so they never got to meet the
Master Codebreaker.
Rian Johnson also had an important storyline
planned for the Master Codebreaker, which
sadly we didn't get to see.
In a deleted subplot, Finn and Rose would
have made contact with him after he finished
playing the piano and singing with a female
alien on stage in the casino's cabaret room.
After talking with him, they would have learned
that he was on the trail of an insectoid warlord
called the Butcher of Brix.
The Codebreaker planned to steal the jewels
that paid for the warlord's brutal regime,
but along with Rose and Finn, he would have
ended up caught by the Canto Bight police
on the casino rooftop, trying to break into
the warlord's room.
And there's more deleted scenes for Finn and
Rose when they get on board Snoke's Supremacy
to find the hyperspace tracker.
Rian Johnson told Collider there's an extended
sequence of Finn, Rose and DJ sneaking through
the Mega Star Destroyer until they arrive
at a "big office area […] and then [have]
to fake out [some] Stormtroopers", which sounds
to me like it could be a hat tip to Han and
Luke in A New Hope.
There's also some concept art which hints
at some of the moments and visual jokes we
might have seen in this sequence.
In one of them, Finn and Rose come across
masses of lint in a tunnel, which they follow
along till they fall through a trap door into
a huge tumble-dryer in the First Order laundry
room.
This scene sounds as if it could have been
reminiscent of the trash compactor scene in
Episode 4 and was probably also a joke at
Finn after he threw Phasma in a trash compactor
in The Force Awakens.
Another piece of concept art then has Rose
and Finn facing off against what they think
is a bunch of Stormtroopers, in a moment evocative
of Han Solo in A New Hope, but in this case,
the Stormtroopers are actually revealed to
be just empty suits on a dry-cleaning rack.
We did get that funny moment in the movie
with the First Order laundry and iron droid
gag, which felt like a nod to the 1978 Star
Wars parody, Hardware Wars; and I think these
deleted scenes would have formed part of that
moment.
Concept art also depicts unused scenes of
Finn and Rose running down a "power converter
hallway" on The Supremacy after they're discovered.
The pair were going to end up in a classic
Star Wars-looking scene on a narrow bridge
with an enormous chasm beneath.
In the end though, the scene was rejected
as Rian Johnson considered it too "on the
nose".
There's still much for us to learn about Snoke
which I'm hoping will be answered in Episode
9, but there was a small deleted moment with
the Supreme Leader in The Last Jedi.
In the cut scene, Snoke would have delivered
a line about his gold slippers, which I imagine
would have fit in with what the Visual Dictionary
says, that he wears them because his physical
frailties cause him to prioritise comfort.
Back on the Jedi Temple island, those little
Porg critters initially had some rather freaky
multi-coloured designs.
And if you thought that scene with Chewie
and a roasted Porg was a bit dark, there's
actually a piece of concept art of a Porg
being impaled by a lightsaber!
It looks like this would have occurred during
the scene when the little creatures were playing
with Luke's abandoned lightsaber.
I doubt there was much chance this would have
made it in to the movie, but if it had, it
would have foreshadowed the way Kylo Ren took
out one of Snoke's Praetorian Guard, with
a lightsaber right through the head.
By the way, if you're wondering whether any
Leia scenes were deleted, Rian Johnson has
only said that no major scenes with Carrie
Fisher were cut.
However, there were some smaller moments cut
that didn't quite work with the final movie.
And actually, I talk about how Leia's deleted
scenes could be used to complete her arc in
Episode 9 in my Carrie Fisher video, which
you can tap in the top right to watch or click
the link in the video description.
Now, what did you think about these deleted
scenes and are there any you wish had been
included in the movie?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and be sure to subscribe to enter the
second round of my Star Wars giveaway.
The winner of the first round of the giveaway
is on the screen right now, so if that's you
send me a private message with your details
and I'll get your prize out to you.
I really appreciate all your support and if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to hit
the thumbs-up button, turn on notifications,
and check out some more videos you're sure
to like right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!